Good news, bad news.
The bad news is that
there actually is no good news,
and the other bad news
is BoJack's gone.
Where did he go?
The shoot is at his house.
I don't even know
why he'd leave.
This charcoal mellow bourbon
is so smooth,
every time I take a sip,
pure happiness.
That was amazing.
Can I get you to say that
in a tuxedo?
Hey, I got to go.
I think this is my big break.
Don't worry. I won't let it get
to my head or anything.
Hey, who told that asshole
he could sit in my chair?
Don't forget I'm your agent,
too, I want ten percent.
Hello, beautiful.
What the hell
are you doing here?
You're supposed to be
shooting a commercial.
I know, but I was sitting
there drinking bourbon and--
They didn't give you
fake bourbon on set?
Oh, they did, and then
I just mixed it with bourbon.
And it hit me.
Why was I so upset
about Diane getting engaged?
You're the one who's always
been there for me,
so I drank a lot more bourbon
and drove over to tell you
how I feel.
Oh, I see what this is.
Princess Carolyn,
what are we doing?
Clearly, we're in love
with each other.
You're not in love with me.
You're in love with Diane.
And you're not even
really in love with her.
You just think you are
because you pay her
to listen to you
talk about yourself.
Diane getting engaged
was the best thing
that ever happened to me.
It made me realize you're
the one I need to be with.
Ha! You say that every time
something bad happens.
Not getting nominated
for a People's Choice Award
is the best thing
that ever happened to me.
It made me realize--
Getting caught
with that pound of cocaine
was the best thing
that ever happened to me.
That hooker getting pregnant
was the best thing
that ever happened to me.
Sneezing on Marisa Tomei
was the best--
Every time
something bad happens,
you come running to me
for comfort.
Well, it's not gonna happen
this time.
I can't be your agent
and your girlfriend.
-It just doesn't work.
-(KNOCKS ON DOOR)
I have Lenny Turteltaub for you.
-I have to take this.
-Okay.
But remember,
I'm coming for you,
and I'm gonna make you love me.
Please don't. Hey.
Bad news, P.C.
Braff used your merger
as an opportunity to jump ship.
Without a director, Eva Braun
is as dead as Eva Braun.
As I once said
to a young Lionel Barr--
Hello? Hello?
Lady, you work too hard.
That was
an important phone call.
Important phone call
beep boop blorp.
Don't you robot-voice me.
Princess Carolyn,
what are we doing?
Well, I'm working,
and you are leaving.
Before I go, I got you
a little sexy something
to remember me by.
Since we can't be together
every second,
I give you cardboard BoJack.
It's got
a light-sensitive sound chip,
so every time you walk by it,
it quotes a line
from Jerry Maguire ,
your favorite movie.
-You complete me.
-I don't have time for you
or cardboard you.
I need to find a new director.
Or you could find
my nude erector--
She's gone.